une fin d'année exceptionnellement
chaudes mais également très bien
ensoleillé cela n'était pas arrivé
depuis 25 ans tous les mois profitent
d'un excédent de soleil sauf juin et
octobre soit deux cent trente six heures
de plus que la normale
météo france a enregistré sept heures de
soleil par jour en moyenne au lieu d'un
peu plus de six heures c'est à dire que
presque tout presque tous les jours les
températures dépasser les 20 et 30
degrés c'est presqu'un record
on n'avait jamais eu aussi chaud durant
tout un mois de décembre et
l'ensoleillement et été très très bons
aussi ajoutez à cela une quantité de
pluie déficitaire à l'exception du mois
d'octobre où il a beaucoup plu sur
l'ensemble de l'année la pluviométrie
annuelle traduit un déficit durable
surtout dans le nord caraïbe et puis re
toujours été presque inférieure à ce
qu'elle devrait être
donc on a eu un déficit de plus décembre
2019 aura été le mois le plus chaud de
l'année en 70 ans deux mesures
c'est une première